when we first moved in here the space
was a little bit depressing
it had this really horrible carpet
flooring and the walls were this weird
yellow i wanted to make sure that our
home office was a place with good energy
and a place where i felt focused and
excited for work hey guys welcome back
to the channel if you're new here my
name is dani and i'm an architect in
vancouver bc and today i'm going to walk
you through my home office
before picking the flooring or the paint
color and later on the furniture i had
to establish a concept for the space the
concept is an idea or the driving force
that forms the foundation and the
identity of every design project and
it's gonna help you make decisions on
all the different aspects of your design
interior designers develop the concept
through what you call a mood board a
mood is a feeling or a state of mind and
the process of identifying the mood is
really
a process of discovery this was a
process that i never really explored in
architecture i actually learned this
during the time i was working at an
interior design firm and i'm not gonna
lie i was a little bit skeptical in the
beginning but it actually became a very
essential part of every interior design
project that i take on so you start by
looking for descriptive words that
represents the feeling or mood you're
trying to achieve and then you look for
images that represent them it was really
important for me to create a really calm
and relaxing and energizing space where
i could come and do my work in a very
focused flow state and i really want to
design the space for my deep work
sessions which is you know primarily how
i use my home office these are some of
the images that i pulled notice how
these images aren't necessarily related
to furniture or building elements but
just something that represents a feeling
once i had my mood board i could use
that to guide my decisions based on this
i picked the honey oak vinyl plank
flooring
i also really wanted to bring some color
into the space so i ended up picking the
sage green as an accent color so this is
a space it's approximately three by four
meters and it's a slightly unusual
configuration uh we have doors here and
here and we have this window that's
slightly off-center from the room and
this area has a slightly lower ceiling
height because of this awkward bulkhead
my boyfriend and i will be sharing the
office space and both of us work from
home part time we need a lot of storage
for books and electronics and other
miscellaneous materials
as well as a lot of drawer space the
configuration of the room naturally made
this into a circulation zone so this
area was dedicated to storage right from
the beginning placing the desks along
the center would give us the walls as
the backdrop when we're doing video
calls but but a lot of wasted space
placing it along this wall didn't quite
give either of us enough space to spread
out
so we actually ended up placing the
desks back to back
this gives us the most space for moving
around and although it's not ideal when
we're doing video calls we try to have
good communication and just be mindful
of each other in this corner we have two
4x2 cadillac shelves which fits nicely
underneath the bulkhead and it keeps
things organized before we get into the
functional items there's one thing that
was driving me insane about this room
and it was this lack of symmetry there's
this bulkhead sticking out and the
window is not centered and let's face it
these doors are in kind of weird places
i wanted to create some alignment
throughout the space so i ended up
buying these muslanda shelves from ikea
cutting them to size and aligning the
perimeter of the room to the height of
the bulkhead it's lined with led strips
to highlight the ceiling i also got
these pegboards from ikea which really
helps to create some order and
creates a grid in the space on the
bottom row is where i keep items that i
access on a daily basis like pens rulers
or memory cards
keys and masks because i always seem to
forget them when i leave the house
things like balance and order might not
feel important to you when you're
planning for a functional workspace but
i think it's really important when
you're trying to create this sense of
harmony and trying to create a space
that's calm and relaxing things i need
to use daily usually sit on my desk and
around my desk either on these pegboards
or on my desk shelf or inside my drawers
and all my books or reference materials
and electronics they sit on the storage
shelf over here i decided to get the two
2x4 cadillacs instead of a 4x4 because
it kind of followed the same grid i was
setting up in the space on either side
of my desk i have the ikea alex drawers
which is divided into different
compartments i also have my hp printer
which i use on a pretty regular basis to
print out images and drawings and mood
boards
now the desk that is where the magic
happens i'll leave the links to
everything in the description but um for
the desk i have a standing desk by effie
desk
which i absolutely love this is the 70
inch large table top in oak white and it
has a almost marbled finish that adds a
little bit of a natural texture i put an
led strip along the back so it has this
nice glow and it really sets the mood
underneath my desk is very exciting i
have a foot reflexology mat which has a
huge number of health benefits and it
just feels amazing when i stand on it
sitting on one of my drawers i also have
a portable drawing board by pacific car
i feel like i don't really get to draw
enough these days but when i do i could
draw on this board for hours on my desk
i have a desk shelf by rob mate this is
one of those things i didn't know i
needed until i had one whenever i have
stray pieces of paper or sketches i just
hide it in my shelf and without having
to actually clean things
my desk looks somewhat perpetually neat
since i use a monitor with my macbook
pro i also got their laptop stand that
slides into the shelf i love the design
of this i think it's smart and elegant
and it really elevates my setup i also
have a walnut pen holder for my copic
pens and a smaller holder for my sage
rollers it's amazing what the sense of
smell can do to your brain and your
overall experience i put on these
rollers and nesting spray and my
diffuser before i start work
and
you might think it's a little bit extra
but
for me it really gets me in the right
mood and i think it's kind of hardwired
my brain for getting into the focus mode
are you okay
in the winter i switch to scented
candles and i go through let's say i go
through many of them i don't think we do
this enough as architects but do you
guys incorporate smell into your designs
on the side i have my nas and my hard
drive holder that i designed and laser
cut for myself because i couldn't find
any other product online i also have a
xiaomi lamp and both the lamp and my
back light can change color temperatures
i tend to use the medium warm around
4000 k the most and in the evenings i
switched to something a little bit
warmer around 3000k right now we just
have these ikea chairs that are not
amazing
we're actually saving up for nice
matching chairs that are both you know
comfortable and aesthetically pleasing
if you have any suggestions for what you
think would work in myspace let me know
it's easy for things to get cluttered
really quickly with too many decorative
elements so i have a very curated number
of things around my workspace that
really spark joy like this little
katsuya ajita house that i got from one
of my subscribers i love the way it
glows in the light i try to bring in
lots of natural elements like these
rocks that i collected on my trips to
vancouver island and i also have a
mixture of live and preserved indoor
plants this is the nesta plant stand
that i got from wayfair and i love how
it adds a softer round element to the
space so that was my home office you
know it's a constantly evolving space
based on our needs but for now it makes
me feel energized and excited for work
every day before we end i want to share
a quick message from our sponsor now i
mentioned that short form is sponsoring
this video but even before they reached
out for a collab i've already been using
their app short form provides super high
quality guides to non-fiction books i
say guides not summaries because their
team of professional writers they don't
only compress the information into a
single page and explain it very clearly
but they also have more in-depth guides
that analyze how it compares to other
more commonly accepted ideas if there's
books that's had a pretty big impact on
my life that i want to reread i can go
here and solidify some of these ideas in
my memory short form is obviously not a
substitute for reading the full book but
i've been tricked into reading books
that could have totally been a one-pager
so before i start reading the book i
read the guides here
to decide if it's actually worth reading
the full book as someone who likes to
read a book slowly
and as someone who has way too many
books on my to-do list short form's a
pretty great way for me to select which
books i actually want to read and it's
also a really great way for me to get
the lessons from the book without
actually reading through the whole book
they're also building up the audio
versions of the guides which can be
pretty handy by joining through the link
in the description you're going to
receive five days of unlimited access
and an additional 20 discount off the
annual subscription which is going to
give you access to thousands of book
guides for the price of one book in a
month
so yeah go check it out
you